The Joe Rogan Experience I used to think
that when I would watch uh Top Gear and
watch the yeah the Stig sure roll around
the track yeah they have their own track
well yeah so Top Gear tests on a old
Runway uh Southwest of London and it's
called dunsfold so they so they ran it
so they have their own but they did I've
been there before I was actually I
brought Steven Tyler over there like 10
years ago to be interviewed by Jeremy
Clarkson those guys so he was a client
we built the Venom GT for him and uh so
we're hanging out and uh I got to see
him go out and do his little celebrity
lap around the truck you know if you're
ever over there and you want to do a
celebrity the star and the reasonably
priced car on connect you with this guys
hilarious yeah it's fun and so I think
they're uh but now you got Chris Harris
and you got the you know Clarkson and
Hammond and may they moved on to Amazon
but uh are they still doing it did they
stop doing it yeah I was I was in London
a couple weeks ago and I saw Richard
Hammond and uh what's the Amazon show
called again uh The Grand Tour right The
Grand Tour and so Clarkson started the
Clark since kind of a wild bombastic guy
he started a show about farming he's got
a farm out in the country and I think
that's really kind of taken off so I
think that's his that's his new gig but
I think they still I think they do still
lose season a year
and uh good entertainment good proper
yeah they're fun proper car stuff a fun
dude yeah what did he punch a producer
they pulled the show well I knew a
little bit about that I was so I was so
we had a we had a velociraptor
um Raptor truck that we were up in
Canada with these guys so this has been
back in 20 into 2014.
and so like I'm I'm working with the
producers and they're like you know when
you're around the talent you know don't
talk to them don't spend time around
them I'm like I'm around famous people
more than These Guys these guys a lot
more famous I mean I don't care that
they're a big deal so anyway so these
The Producers kind of being a dick and
so we show up with these guys and then
we're like provide the vehicle
and then and they're going to go
cross-country through Canada and through
the mountains and do all this crazy [__]
and then they're going to go up on the
mountain they're going to rescue Richard
Hammond who's at the top of the mountain
he's got one of these Breitling watches
where you pull out the little cord and
it tells the satellite that you're
stranded so it gives your coordinates to
get rescued anyway so now the producers
are saying well you know uh you can't go
up on the mountain while they're filming
I'm like okay but listen to this I'm
gonna go watch football it's the
playoffs I'm gonna go watch football and
if something breaks and you need us to
help you we're not coming they're like
oh then they change their tune like okay
we'll come with this and finally it all
it all turns out fine well that producer
I won't say his name but that producer
it was being a massive dick and maybe he
was just doing his job like two weeks
later they're somewhere else in there in
England and Jeremy you know Jeremy's
gets a little bit of a temper and these
guys work long hours and maybe they
hadn't eaten and the producer guy was
[__] with him
Jeremy [__] whacked the guy and I'm
like I wanted to [__] punch that guy
a couple times too
but I can't do that and I don't want to
get arrested in Canada anyway yeah so
they they
cancel the show yeah and it didn't
Jeremy and him make up but they're still
like uh you know I'm sure that's all you
know water under the bridge but Jeremy
so Jeremy Richard Hammond and James May
were all very tight I've spent time
around them and then the other guy
that's
behind the scenes but just so talented
his name is Andy Willman he was the
producer when they were on BBC now he's
the producer but uh when Stephen Tyler
was being interviewed you're like this
from your comedy part of your brain when
Stephen was being interviewed by Jeremy
I noticed that the interview went on for
like twice as long as it probably should
have and I don't I get claustrophobic so
I don't like being in tight crowds so
I'm kind of hanging towards the back of
the crowd that they're filming all this
live and then they aired it later but
they're filming in front of a live
audience and here this this guy that
looks like he's a homeless dude wearing
a t-shirt looked like he hadn't showered
in about a week he's standing there
making notes
and I realized I was Andy woman the
producer of the show and so what
Jeremy's doing he's asked he's telling
all these jokes and asking these
questions and Andy is using the live
audience as his focus group oh they
laughed at this oh I don't I don't think
this is as funny and that's how they
edit it before that before it goes uh
gets transmitted to the rest of the UK
in the world interesting I thought that
is so clever that is so smart you know
and I don't know if that you know
comedians or entertainers kind of but
you know you would think to some degree
you want to improve your crap but he's
got a quick turnaround time so like he's
got another show he's got to do the
following week so he's just like
Jeremy's doing all this stuff and
sometimes they laugh and sometimes it
wouldn't but this guy was definitely
paying attention that show uh Top Gear
did Tesla dirty you know yeah they did
oh they did they did all kinds of
crooked [__] but they did Tesla I mean
they pretended the car ran out of
batteries oh yeah now the car didn't so
they had like their push in the car and
you know they I think they had a lawsuit
about that because they probably did but
that goes back to like we were talking
about earlier like it just seems like
that was dirty it seems like everybody
has as an agenda so what was the agenda
behind that was that just the the well
they wanted to create an entertaining
storyline
they'll throw your ass under the bus and
a heartbeat that was what it is yeah oh
Tesla attempted to sue the BBC for libel
March of 2011 the courts ruled in favor
of the BBC saying that no viewer of the
show would be likely to reasonably
compare the roadster's performance on
the show with its performance in the
real world that doesn't make any sense
yeah no they got they got well they got
railroad British courts sites with
British Corporation that's owned by the
British government against American
company oops Yeah they got railroaded
yeah because the idea that watching this
thing break down wouldn't influence you
to not get one yeah like these people
are testing it and it breaks down look
those guys good or bad we should just
say what happened yeah while we're
saying it yeah because their car didn't
really break down right they faked it no
they faked it and faked it they they did
it just to sort of make a point about
what could happen with electric cars but
it's a fake it was manufactured deal led
to your point but like like you know
they they just want eyeballs you know so
the more definitely the more
controversial yeah the when uh you know
one time when Jeremy was driving this
truck and they were like what would
happen if we ran into a brick wall
he ended up going to the hospital and
getting you know broken ribs and
whatever else just to shoot the video of
this guy so they'll do anything they
weren't they ran into a brick wall
Jeremy Clarkson he did yeah with a truck
it's on YouTube yeah they got a they got
a video camera they got a GoPro inside
and he it does I mean he went to the
hospital yeah he went to the hospital
from that and then how did you do that
they did and they because retention dude
they are these guys were the masters of
jumping the Sharks season after season
after season you heard about the deal
when they went to Argentina what did let
me see the what's one step at a time let
me see the truck slamming into the wall
yeah before we get to Argentina yeah
because I just can't believe that they
were just driving Clarkson Top Gear full
acceler race truck crash no they each
each guy had to do it and they're all
wearing their safety equipment it might
have been 20 miles an hour I mean just
just run as fast as you can into that
yeah wood wall over there it's gonna
[__] hurt you know
so yeah well I think you could
legitimately you could die
oh yeah oh it's one of these trucks yeah
oh boy yeah look at this
he's going pretty good
bro he's going very fast
that is so crazy so do you think these
guys give a [__] about hurting Elon and
his company is so cool they want views
yeah his neck's got to be [__] up from
that yeah we did a thing with them a
grand tour in Detroit about five years
ago and he you know maybe he's got a
good chiropractor he looks like he's
healed up but man that that's pretty
gnarly that seems like it could cause
permanent damage and so they would do
stuff like that well that even happened
recently caused some discs injury he
suffered on the show another one another
one of their guys in the in the current
crew I forget his name maybe Pato
O'Rourke but anyway he uh um he had a
bad car crash that canceled the whole
season really the rest of the season
yeah and again nobody really knows the
details they're not showing anything but
I I hear was pretty painful yeah so well
you watch that image he reaches for his
neck like immediately and you see how
his head violent snaps yeah I don't know
how it doesn't uh break break your neck
so just like stuff like that like when
we were in Canada with the with the crew
we're hanging out with the crew and like
the the so they went down to Canada they
weren't not Canada they went Argentina
excuse me the gummy bear is kicking in I
suppose uh they're in Argentina and so
in one of the cars they made they rode
on the car they're doing this
cross-country thing
they're kind of poking fun at the
argentinians when they lost the Falcon
War back in the 80s to the Brits and and
the story was that these guys were
getting chased out of the country like
people were gonna like looking for them
if they found them they were gonna
freaking you know beat their ass pretty
hard or worse and so I'm talking to the
crew and
um you know the the presenters were able
to get to Buenos Aires and were able to
get out of the country but the crew was
still there and people are like they're
calling the embassy they're like hey you
know what can we do the [__] locals
are trying to get us and so I guess the
present this again this is what I'm
hearing from the crew when we were in
Canada with our Velociraptor uh is that
um you know the presenters got out the
crew were stuck fearing for their lives
like hiding out in places trying to make
it to the airport to get home and then
so when the whole [__] hit the fan the
the presenters in England felt bad for
him so they bought them all first class
tickets or business class from from
Argentina back to the UK
but then the question becomes kind of
given the pattern of wanting to further
jump the shark and look I'm I'm if I
climb a mountain I want to I want to
climb the next Mountain so I get that to
some degree
but did these guys actually like try to
stir up the locals by putting [__] on
their card of course they [__] with them
well yeah just for notoriety and so I
mean I mean yeah yeah I would think so I
mean 100 why else did you do it yeah
you're trying to be nice yeah I don't
know if they knew it was going to go as
far but man they but it's kind of a
shitty deal where they they skated out
of there and their crew is literally you
know afraid they were going to get
[__] Beat to Death imagine if they
did yeah yeah so that and and I'm
hearing this from the crew and this Auto
had gone down like 30 days before Jesus
yeah yeah it's kind of interesting but
you know